but when we say things like how bad men
are and men are trash like you don't you
don't think that shows there's some
disadvantage for men because that's the
way people view them
yeah oh oh I'm sorry Mrs do you know
anyone that's ever been can you get
this is
right
yes
I know I know a guy that's been do you
know a female that's Evan no actually
yeah so I know I know I know yeah I know
I went to sleep in a wreck in a living
room with people that I've been living
with for three weeks I went to sleep in
a living room and I woke up with a man
with his beside me and you know what I
did you know what I did I made a joke by
because I didn't want to hurt his ego I
didn't want to hurt his feelings so
don't talk about this [__] saying like
oh yeah let's let's not talk about men's
feelings